Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
Oggi vi parlerò di seconda identità.
Di seconda identità, di secondo io,
di secondo me stesso.
Cercherò di parlarvi di questo
a partire da che cosa?
Dall'impatto delle novità tecnologiche,
che stanno cambiando totalmente
la nostra vita personale,
la vita economica, la vita politica,
l'educazione, i rapporti sociali,
i rapporti interpersonali - tutto.
Che cos'è la seconda identità?
Non è mai esistita prima,
questa è la vera novità:
non abbiamo mai avuto
una seconda identità, prima.
Oggi, se io devo fare il vero paragone
tra la mia generazione
e la generazione dei più giovani,
dei ragazzi che oggi
hanno 15, 20, 25 anni,
io penso che la vera differenza
sia proprio sull'impatto della tecnologia.
Negativa per me, per noi:
siamo molto più scarsi,
[voi] siete molto più smart.
Positiva per noi:
ogni stupidaggine che facevamo
non lasciava traccia da nessuna parte;
ogni stupidaggine che fate
lascia traccia -
potete perdere il posto di lavoro
perché avete postato una stupidaggine,
senza nemmeno immaginarvi le conseguenze
che la cosa avrebbe avuto.
Perché quando io ho fatto
i primi colloqui di lavoro, da ragazzo,
avevo la mia faccia, la mia parlantina,
tre righe di uno scarno curriculum,
delle cose fatte fino a quel momento.
Niente di più.
Potevo, in fondo, intortare
il mio interlocutore assai facilmente.
Quando parlerete con un vostro
potenziale datore di lavoro,
il vostro datore di lavoro
potrà guardare tutto di voi, chi siete.
Perché oggi, attraverso
le novità della tecnologia,
abbiamo una seconda identità,
abbiamo un altro noi stessi.
E tutta la nostra vita è tracciata,
in modo totalmente diverso
da com'era prima.
Che cosa vuol dire, allora,
una seconda identità?
Beh, intanto vuol dire questo.
Vuol dire che questo,
cioè il nostro telefono mobile,
che abbiamo da tanti anni ormai,
molti anni;
ma da qualche anno a questa parte,
questo telefono mobile è molto di più
di quello che era fino adesso.
Qualche anno fa,
potevamo in fondo definirlo
una cosa abbastanza neutra:
era come l'aria condizionata,
forse addirittura come un'automobile.
O forse possiamo paragonarlo
a qualunque altro elettrodomestico
che avevamo in casa.
Adesso, questa è la seconda identità.
È la mia seconda identità,
è la vostra seconda identità,
il mobile che avete nelle vostre tasche.
Perché dico questo?
Perché qui dentro
c'è tutto quello che io sono,
tutte le persone con cui ho parlato,
tutti i siti che ho visitato.
Qui dentro ci sono tutte le modalità
per capire chi sono,
se guido bene o se guido male,
dove sono in un certo momento,
dove sono stato:
veramente, c'è tutto me stesso,
tutto qui dentro.
Chi controlla questo
controlla tutto quello che io penso,
tutti i miei gusti.
Tanto che alle volte uno va qui
e vede che lui ti conosce meglio
di come ti conosci te stesso.
E alla fine, qui dentro c'è tutto.
E questo tutto è impressionante
perché non c'è mai stato un luogo, prima,
dove fosse racchiusa
la mia identità, la mia persona.
La mia persona ero io, prima di questo;
e adesso invece sono io,
e poi c'è anche lui.
Perché qui dentro, in sintesi,
c'è stoccato tutto me stesso.
Ed è fuori dal mio corpo,
e qualcuno ci può entrare,
molto più di quanto qualcuno possa entrare
nella mia persona,
nella mia vera prima identità.
Che cosa vuol dire
che qualcuno può entrare qui dentro?
Vuol dire che, ormai,
questi telefoni mobili -
qualche anno fa erano europei:
molti avevano il Nokia,
c'era una certa tecnologia europea;
oggi non c'è più.
Questi telefoni che abbiamo
in tasca, sostanzialmente,
sono o americani o coreani o cinesi.
Il che vuol dire
che tutti i dati che noi abbiamo
sono stoccati lontano da casa nostra,
e chi ha in mano questi strumenti
ha in mano, anche,
la nostra seconda identità.
Nel futuro, le guerre
non si combatteranno, secondo me,
per i motivi per cui
si sono combattute in passato:
petrolio, frontiere.
Credo che le guerre
si combatteranno, soprattutto,
per capire chi userà, sfrutterà,
sarà proprietario di questi dati.
Perché alla fine,
con questi dati, effettivamente,
si potranno vincere campagne elettorali,
si potranno controllare i mercati,
si potranno avere campagne
di marketing efficaci,
si potrà sapere cosa pensa la gente,
quali sono i gusti della gente;
si potranno ricattare aziende,
nazioni e persone.
E allora la seconda identità,
il secondo me stesso
che diventa, oggi, la vera questione
sulla quale affrontare,
dal punto di vista filosofico,
etico, politico, democratico, sociale,
le regole e il modo
col quale sarà il futuro.
E questa seconda identità è qui dentro.
E la tecnologia che governa
la mia seconda identità
noi europei l'abbiamo totalmente persa.
I telefonini che abbiamo in mano
sono o americani, o cinesi, o coreani.
Qualche anno fa avevamo
telefonini anche europei:
oggi, praticamente, nemmeno più.
E abbiamo perso la partita
della tecnologia, i dati miei -
io sono sul telefonino americano,
stanno da qualche parte
a Cupertino, in California.
Non so chi li può sfruttare,
chi ne è proprietario, chi li gestisce.
Non lo so.
[E] non ho, francamente, nessuna fiducia
nel fatto che chi può avere
accesso a quei dati
possa avere, nella scelta
tra proteggere la mia identità personale
o fare profitti attraverso questi dati,
possa facilmente essere portato
a scegliere la seconda delle opzioni.
Ci sono stati tanti casi già oggi:
io mi ricordo Cambridge
Analytica e Facebook,
un caso di una gravità senza precedenti
che è stato messo a tacere,
e non se ne parla quasi più,
ma fa capire quali sono
le potenziali derive di tutto ciò.
E allora, dicevo,
Stati Uniti, Asia e noi europei
che abbiamo perso la partita
della tecnologia qui dentro.
Che cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che gli Stati Uniti,
su questi temi, che approccio hanno?
Molto spesso, quando pensiamo
alla questione della regolazione
di queste materie negli Stati Uniti,
abbiamo evidente l'impressione
che li è la competitività
dell'industria hi-tech che deve vincere.
La protezione della privacy,
o della proprietà personale,
o appunto dei dati personali,
sembra che venga molto dietro.
Almeno, questa è l'impressione
che io francamente ho.
A me non piace questo tipo di approccio.
Ma se guardo all'Asia,
all'altro tipo di modello,
se guardo alla Cina,
l'impressione è che ci sia
un approccio diverso,
un approccio quasi opposto:
l'utilizzo di quei dati,
di quella seconda identità
per, in una transizione
molto facile, molto veloce,
entrare nella prima identità
della persona.
Che è inviolabile - o dovrebbe,
essere inviolabile -
ma tramite questa
seconda identità ci entri.
E lo Stato può avere l'interesse,
attraverso questi dati,
a controllare chi sono, che gusti ho,
quali sono i miei comportamenti.
E qui si entra in uno
degli snodi fondamentali
del futuro della vita.
Perché io credo che lo Stato
debba essere molto netto
nel sanzionarmi se sbaglio,
se rompo una regola
che lo Stato ha messo:
ma io non penso che lo Stato
debba intervenire
a prescindere dal fatto
che io rompa le regole.
La mia persona è inviolabile,
anche nella seconda identità
che oggi è stoccata nel mio telefonino.
E allora, se è cosi,
come riuscire a vincere questa guerra,
questa guerra di influenza
su chi riuscirà a imporre delle regole
che proteggano la persona
rispetto all'invasività o alla corsa
di questi giganti dell'industria hi-tech?
Tornano di moda due parole molto demodé,
che sono la Politica e l'Unione Europea.
Perché la Politica
e l'Unione Europea?
Perché è evidente che,
o è la politica che regola tutto ciò,
oppure lo farà il mercato.
Oppure, semplicemente,
lo Stato imporrà la sua volontà.
E io, francamente, sono terrorizzato.
Mi viene la pelle d'oca a pensare
che sia il mercato a regolare tutto ciò,
perché qui ne vanno di mezzo
i diritti della persona.
Ed è la politica che deve decidere.
La politica, cioè noi:
non il mercato, non le aziende hi-tech.
Credo che sia meglio anche per loro,
avere delle regole da applicare,
e non essere di fronte alla tentazione.
Ma allo stesso tempo,
c'è di mezzo l'Unione Europea.
Perché l'Unione Europea?
Perché, come dicevo prima, l'impressione
è che gli altri giganti del mondo
vadano su strade diverse.
Noi europei,
che noi siamo svedesi, portoghesi,
italiani, francesi, tedeschi,
abbiamo la stessa filosofia:
la filosofia che ci porta a dire
che la persona è inviolabile.
E la stiamo traslando
in una transizione etica,
democratica e filosofica,
anche sulla seconda identità.
Perché lì c'è la mia persona:
messa, stoccata, sintetizzata,
ma è la mia persona, ed è inviolabile
così come la mia prima persona.
E se in Europa avessimo 28 Brexit,
come hanno fatto i britannici -
immaginiamoci una dissoluzione,
ognuno per conto suo -
non avremmo nessuna capacità
di imporre agli altri questa filosofia,
che come accennavo prima
è veramente tipica nostra,
dei nostri valori
e della nostra civiltà giuridica.
Ecco perché l'Europa unita, oggi,
ha una missione in più.
È una missione diversa,
e molto più impegnativa
e più importante, anche,
delle vecchie missioni
che le abbiamo sempre dato.
È importante per la pace,
è sempre stata importante per la pace,
è sempre stata importante
per l'abbattimento delle frontiere,
per trovare regole comuni di convivenza,
per lo sviluppo,
per la rappresentanza
dell'Europa nel mondo.
Ma qui di mezzo c'è molto di più:
qui di mezzo c'è il futuro
delle nostre persone.
E non è fantascienza:
quando si parla di queste cose,
sembra che si stia parlando
di fantascienza.
Ma riflettete sul fatto che due anni fa,
questi discorsi io stesso
non li avrei mai fatti:
oggi, secondo me, sono
la chiave di tutto, il cuore di tutto.
E attenzione: questa
è la seconda identità,
e il discorso sulla seconda identità.
Forse fra due anni ci ritroveremo qui,
e sarei tentato di fare -
magari non io, che non
ne capisco niente di queste cose,
ma qualcun altro -
di fare del discorso
su un'altra seconda identità,
che è l'Intelligenza Artificiale,
che è la macchina,
quello che la macchina farà al mio posto.
Un altro secondo me stesso.
Quali sono le regole con cui agirà
questo secondo me stesso?
E credo che qui capiamo
che cosa vuol dire questa evoluzione.
È il fatto che, anche qui,
la politica per un verso deve decidere -
e non deve essere il mercato:
non deve essere nemmeno
la tecnologia, a decidere -
e allo stesso tempo l'Unione Europea
deve imporre, e deve imporsi,
con le sue regole di civiltà giuridica,
basate sul rispetto della centralità
e dell'inviolabilità della persona.
In sintesi, e in conclusione,
se tutto quello che ho detto
fino adesso ha un senso, è vero,
e in questa transizione
verso un futuro ipertecnologico
ha una qualche logica,
allora la politica
è decisiva, è importante
e non possiamo abbandonarla così.
E l'Unione Europea
è decisiva e importante.
L'Unione Europea unita,
non sbrandellata e ognuno per conto suo.
L'Unione Europea unita.
Io penso al mio futuro,
penso al futuro dei miei figli,
ma credo che ognuno di noi faccia,
o possa fare, lo stesso ragionamento
Non voglio un futuro
in cui devo essere costretto a scegliere
se essere una colonia americana
o una colonia cinese: non mi piace.
Mi piacciono gli americani,
mi piacciono i cinesi;
ma io voglio essere italiano
e voglio essere europeo.
Non voglio avere la scelta
tra essere una colonia americana o cinese.
Voglio avere la possibilità
di sviluppare i miei valori,
i valori centrati sul rispetto totale
dell'inviolabilità della persona.
Per me vuol dire essere italiano
ed essere europeo.
E soltanto con una politica forte,
e un Unione Europea unita
e altrettanto forte,
si potranno affrontare questi temi.
E potremo essere, potrò essere,
potremmo tutti riflettere sul fatto
che l'inviolabilità della persona,
per noi, è il centro di tutto.